it's Independence Day so aliens are back
and there are none too pleased about
losing their last battle on earth as
part of their plan for revenge they move
one of their large ships over the
surface of the earth the ship is so
massive that it starts to
gravitationally rip the Earth's surface
towards it
but could this ever be for reals like
for reals reals
first things first gravitational force
is an attractive interaction between any
two objects with mass that means that if
the earth pulls down on a person the
person also pulls up on the earth so in
order for a building to actually be
lifted up the gravitational attraction
to the spaceship has to be at least as
large as that of the earth we don't
really get a good view of this
spacecraft so let's just guess that it's
5,000 meters above the surface of the
earth so if it were to have a
gravitational effect from our
calculations the spaceship would need a
mass of 3.7 quintillion kilograms yeah
that's about the same weight of an
asteroid with the radius of about 70
kilometers but really who's to say mass
is the only thing that can create
gravitational fields or maybe the
explanation is thank God nothing this is
a science fiction movie for pete's sake
on top of that it's an Independence Day
movie which doesn't get a hoot about the
laws of physics